[تصفيق]
من هنا من مركب محمد الخامس
امام المنتخب البلجيكي متفاجئ غير متفاجى
حدا اعتقد من الجماهير مصدوم بالنتيجه او
مش متوقعه هلا اعتقد ذلك منتخب المغرب
واحد من افضل المنتخبات اللي موجوده في
هذه البطوله على المستوى الشخصي هذا
اعتقاد الشخص يعني عنده لاعبين مميزين
بيلعبوا باكبر الانديه الاوروبيه عنده
القدره انه ينافس اكبر منتخب في اوروبا
ويقدم امامه مستويات كبيره ولكن الصعوبه
في منتخب المغرب هي فكره التحضير الدهني
للمباريات وكيف بدك تحضرون لحتى يفوتوا
يلعبوا ويفوزوا
ويحققونا نتائج ويلعبوا بالشكل يلعبوا فيه
اليوم امام المنتخب
المغربي اليوم اللي عمله انه بكل بساطه
قطع الماء والكهرباء
مفتاح اللاعب الرئيسي بالنسبه للمنتخب
البلجيكي كيف اند بروين كانت مقطوعه عن
الماء والكهرباء اليوم داخل ارضيه الملعب
من جانب لاعبي وسط المنتخب المغربي اللي
كانوا ناجحين بشكل كبير بقطع واخفال كل
زوايا التمرير وهذا الامر اللي اكدوا
اناحي لكي تصريحات خاصه لسيران بعد
المباراه وقال نحن اعتمدنا على قطع واقفال
زوايا التمرير على كيفن دي بروين اللي ما
كان مبين نهائيا في هذه المباراه طبعا دي
بروين يعني انتقادات غوارديولا يبدو انها
في مكانها الاندرويد اليوم حركته كانت
كثير بطيئه وكان كثير ثقيل بدون كره ولكن
رغم ذلك المنتخب المغربي كان قادر يعزله
تماما يمنع وصول الكره له بشكل تقريبا
شبهتها تمام وهذا الامر الذي خفف وقلل من
خطوره بلجيكا بشكل كبير جدا جدا
دايس وعلى عقار وعلى بقيه الدفاع المغرب
الرائع وعلى الحارس ايضا منير المحمدي
اللي لعب في الدقائق الاخيره قبل المباراه
طبعا همم دخل مكان ياسين بونو بعد ما طلع
التشكيل الرسميه بوجود بونو بونه تعرض على
ما يبدو يا اما لوعكه صحيه ياما الاصابه
بعد ما بنعرف اسالنا مزراوي على الموضوع
ولكن اجابته كانت مضامين انه مش عارف قال
احنا كنا مركزين بالمباراه ولكن كان في
عرض صحي منع بونو انه يشارك في هذه
المباراه وبالتالي منير محمد قدم مباراه
كبيره جدا ايضا تالق في بعض اكثر من كره
المنتخب البلجيكي من تسجيلات بعد شويه من
غيرها من الكرات الصعبه كانت
وبالتالي المنتخب البلجيكي كان عاجز تماما
عن الوصول الى مرمى المغرب خلف الان
جماهير المغربيه تغني طبعا الاغاني اللي
استوحتها من الجمهور السعودي عن لوكاكو
بكل الاحوال المنتخب المغربي بالشوط الاول
كان متراجع دفاعيا كان يلعب بالدفاع عميق
نوعا ما كان في تعليمات لحكيمي ومصراوي
بعدم التقدم للامام بالاعتماد على اللاعب
في الخلف وعدم المخاطره في الشوط الاول
بالشوط الثاني شفنا تقدمات ومساعده اكبر
من قبل اظهرت المنتخب المغربي وباوامر
ايضا كان هذا امر واضح جدا داخل ارضيه
الملعب شفنا تفاهم اكبر في المباراه
الثاني بين الاجنحه والاظهره في شوط
المباراه الاول كانت دفاعيا رائعه جدا منع
المنتخب المغربي اي كره ان تصل لمنمار او
تهدد مرماه بشكل مباشر في شوط المباراه
الاول بفضل تالق والتمركز السليم من جانب
سايس ومن جانب عكار المساند الدفاعيه من
جانب مرابط
سواء التمرير مثل ما حكينا بجانب اناحي
ومن جانب املاح
المسارد الدفاعيه من جانب زياش وابو فهد
هاي العمليه كلها خلقت منظومه قويه جدا
دفاعيا سجل المنتخب المغربي هدف في وقت
رائع جدا في الشوط المباراه الاول بدقيقه
46 ولكن هدف الغيها بسبب انه سايز كان في
موقع التسلل حتى بالهدف الثاني اللي سجلوا
صبيري كان ممكن ايضا ساسي يكون في موقع
التسلل ولكن همم ربما ما كان متسلل في تلك
اللحظه بس كان ممكن يحط المتغير المغربي
بمشكله كبيره تبديلات وليد كانت رائعه جدا
ادخال سبيري كان بالوقت المناسب ادخال همم
اللاعب ابو خلال الذي سجل الهدف الثاني
كان ايضا بالوقت المناسب يعني هدفين
سجلوهم بدلاء وهذا شغل مدرب هذا شغل كبير
من جانب وليدي هذا شغل كبير من جانب
المنتخب المغربي اللي يبدو انه انه عنده
عمق تشكيل رائع جدا عنده عمق تشكيله كبيره
جدا وبالتالي هذا الامر اللي اثر اجابه من
اليوم يبدا التشكيل عند المنتخب المغربي
كان اكبر منه عند المنتخب البلجيكي في هذه
المباراه تخيل يرعاك الله وبالتالي المغرب
استحق الفوز بلا شك المغرب الان حظوظه الى
التاهل اصبحت قويه جدا امام مباراه كندا
لازم يتعامل معها مثل ما حكينا مع احد
الصحفيين الزملاء المغاربه في المنطقه
المختلطه وتحدثنا عن موضوع انه المغرب يجب
ان يحترم كندا في المباراه القادمه لازم
يلعب مع كندا مثل ملعب اليوم مع بلجيكا
ويتفوق على المنتخب الكندي بنتيجه كبيره
معلش
كبيره بكاس العالم ويوصل لدور ال 16 متصدر
لهذه المجموعه مبروك لجمهور المغربي مبروك
للجميع واا هارد لك المشجعين المنتخب
البلجيكي وقال ان شاء الله المغاربه
الوصول الى الدور الثاني
[موسيقى]